bonsoir benoît mur ascione merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france les
promesses de dons de 1 7 milliard de
dollars pour le yémen jugées décevantes
selon l'onu est ce que vous partagez
cette opinion bonsoir oui et sans en
être très étonné les les états dont la
france
enfin que font le commerce des armes et
qu'il leur apporte chaque année un peu
plus d'un milliard avec danser dans ses
ventes avec l'arabie saoudite est un peu
plus un peu moins avec les émirats
arabes unis on est dans un déchaînement
des valeurs au niveau des gouvernements
pas au niveau des peuples et au niveau
des gouvernements qui est absolument
effarant et on se demande comment les
nations unies font parce que à chaque
fois qu'ils communiquent ils sont
obligés de trouver des superlatifs
supplémentaire car la situation ne fait
qu'empirer et en 2019 à 2019 le venue de
le programme des nations unies pour le
développement avait évalué à plus de 230
mille morts des conséquences directes et
indirectes de cette guerre et nous
sommes maintenant plus d'une année de
cette triste oublions la solution pour
vous allez peut-être simpliste mais elle
est claire à ce que ça serait tout
simplement que les pays étrangers
arrêtent de vendre des armes qui
serviront au yémen oui c'est d'ailleurs
ce que le président le nouveau président
des états unis a compris l heureux
véritablement poussé par une bonne
partie du congrès qu'ils allaient voter
déjà par trois fois
la demande d'arrêt des ventes d'armes et
de soutien à cette guerre au yémen
ils l'ont fait parce qu'il savait qu'ils
avaient des crimes de guerre nous avons
fait un rapport au sein d'edf qui montre
qu'il s'agit bien de crimes contre
l'humanité c'est sur notre site
azer tirer à ce point org et vous plaît
donc que consulter ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que les experts des
nations unies on n'a pas demandé aux
experts des nations unies
de faire des recherches justement sur la
qualification de crimes contre
l'humanité dans cette guerre c'est
extrêmement dommageable il serait
absolument temps de le faire et de
donner à ces mêmes experts les mêmes
moyens qui ont été données par exemple
dans la guerre ou s'il y en a un
sentiment que les instances
internationales notamment d'ailleurs
l'europe 1 à commencer par l'europe n'a
pas justement cette prise de conscience
est l'intérêt économique qui prime avant
tout et où le cynisme a finalement c'est
honteux pas dire l'europe parce que
l'intérêt de l'europe qui ait eu des
décisions courageuses notamment
d'allemagne
oui et puis même si l'allemagne a encore
des choses à régler parce que il ya des
industries allemandes rail métal qui
continue d'exporter les armes par
d'autres pays notamment d'afrique du sud
et jusqu'à quelques jours l'italie
l'italie le gouvernement italien
aussi après une mesure extrêmement
courageuse en suspendant toutes les
exportations d'armes en direction de
l'arabie saoudite et des émirats arabes
unis la france la grande bretagne et
l'espagne sont maintenant absolument
isolé dans le monde et ce qui est encore
plus terrible c'est que le gouvernement
français continue de suivre son
aveuglement et quand il déclare par
exemple justesse et condamne les
attaques des outils sur la région de
marib et sur la ville de marib à peu
près deux millions d'habitants
il oublie de rappeler à l'arabie
saoudite aux émirats arabes unis et
leurs alliés dont l'egypte leurs
obligations et notamment sur la question
humanitaire puisque les deux parties
bloc presque systématiquement les
arrivées humanitaires notamment par le
port de départ y la france dans le
parlement évidemment ne contrôle pas les
ventes d'armes stress à l'élever de
solutions c'est ce que nous avions
demandé en 1997 une coalition de lg en
france qui demandait est ce que il y un
office parlementaire qui concerne donc
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat puis
trollé a posteriori les ventes d'armes
de la france et de voir s'ils sont bien
respectueuse des engagements
internationaux de notre pays
malheureusement le dernier rapport le
deuxième et dernier rapport qui est
sorti sur les exportations d'armes en
france et un rapport parlementaire
il était dirigé par madame tabarot et
monsieur le maire monsieur maire
reprenne notre idéal à des voyants parce
qu'ils demandent que tout cela se fasse
en secret or c'est une histoire qui
regardent les citoyens français et dont
sont bien sûr les parlementaires et il
est absolument urgent que les
parlementaires puissent enfin trouvé le
courage de s'engager comme le fait par
exemple sébastien nadeau plusieurs fois
l'assemblée nationale il a demandé une
enquête indépendante sur les gendarmes
de la france notamment en direction des
pays de la diriger par la coalition
dirigée par l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis pour vous les
explications années qu économique c'est
une manne financière très importante
pour évidemment la france enquête
de remplir les caisses de l'état bien
sûr regardé des sommes véritablement
vers si puisqu'on sait pas ce qui est
véritablement versé par exemple la
france 1 re et vendu des rafale et des
mistral les navires mistral à l'egypte
qu'il ne les a pour l'instant notre
connaissance jamais payé donc cessons
les contribuables français qui l'a qui
paye
mais non c'est les sommes sont ridicules
quand on pense même au pib français
ça représente 0 0 les quelques pour cent
du pib français non non ce sont des des
choix cynique stratégique soit disant
stratégique et c'est une stratégie de la
mort on se rappelle quand même que cette
guerre a renforcé
al-qaïda dans la péninsule arabique et
que notamment parce que c'est les alliés
de la france
transférer des armes ces groupes
responsables d'actes de terrorisme
notamment en france
donc non il ya quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave qui se passe
aujourd'hui et malheureusement les
journaux français sont très très peu en
parler heureusement l'humanité a sorti
un article fait un numéro là dessus la
semaine dernière mais le monde quel que
soit nommée de noter le yémen alors que
dans les déclarations par exemple du
pape le pape deux fois à relever la
situation du yémen la gravité de la
situation du yémen et demandé aux états
et aux gouvernements de prendre leurs
responsabilités comme l'ont fait aussi
les experts des nations unies sont
demandé à ce que les pays qui exportait
des armes cessent pour qu'enfin on
puisse avoir un espace de dialogue dans
ce pays comment vous expliquez cette on
va la qualifier d'indifférence m'enfin
ça serait peut-être déjà un jugement en
tout cas d'absence
justement ce sujet du yémen dans les
colonnes de la presse française
d'après nos informations les saoudiens
ont payé les agences publicis et la
basse pour éviter qu'on parle mal de ce
qui se passe au yémen
visiblement leur tactique semble être
très efficace ça veut dire qu'il ya un
lobbying auprès de la presse française
pour qu'on évite de parler du gay men et
accessoirement du coup delà de la vente
d'armes
c'est ce que nous avons rassemblés dans
notre travail sur le yémen aux
fonctionnaires foncé qui a travaillé
notamment sur arbitres l'a déclaré
plusieurs fois et je me chauffe son soin
à ses propos merci benoît mais raciale
président de l'association action
sécurité éthique républicaine d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france